y la gran pregunta es si pensaba estaba
inhabilitación sobre freddy superlano
porque ese acepto su candidatura
bueno la verdad es que el consejo
electoral no recibió ningún oficio de
parte de la contraloría general de la
república
referente a la inhabilitación de freddy
superlano
desde el 31 de agosto
en el cn sí recibió oficios para la
inhabilitación de otros 24
líderes políticos
17 de los cuales estaban postulados de
distintos cargos y tuvieron que ser
sustituidos algunos de ellos incluso se
recibieron después de cerrado el proceso
de postulación es el 16 de noviembre y
esos cargos quedaron esas postulaciones
quedaron vacantes y quien votó por esos
candidatos voto nulo de manera de que el
oficio de inhabilitación de su perla no
nunca llegó al cn a pesar de que si
llegaron otros y por eso él figuraba en
los instrumentos electorales y recibió
pues una votación suficiente para ser
adjudicado y programado gobernador señor
víctor no creo que esta decisión ahora
pone en cuestión la transparencia
anunciada por el gobierno antes de los
comicios
definitivamente es un retroceso que pone
una mancha sobre el proceso electoral
del 21 de noviembre en este proceso
lograron participar casi 9 millones de
electores
un
45% más de los que participaron en las
elecciones parlamentarias del 6 de
diciembre 2020 y el resultado pues
refleja una pluralidad política ya que
digamos distintos factores de oposición
obtuvieron más de 120 alcaldías además
de tres gobernaciones
y bueno eso es un avance digamos que
representa una ganancia para el país que
se represente en el mapa político de
alcaldías de gobernaciones la
posibilidad del trabajo conjunto entre
los factores de oposición de trabajo y
los y los factores de gobierno sin
embargo pues esta decisión pues atenta
contra la autonomía del poder electoral
el rector marque y yo dimos la discusión
en el directorio de que esto debía ser
rechazado pero bueno se impuso la
mayoría tres a dos y ahorita lo que nos
queda es repetir la elección el estado
harina el próximo 9 de enero de 2022 a
eso precisamente iba la elección se
pospone para enero pero quien estará en
representación de freddy superlano
bueno el proceso de postulación es
justamente comenzó hoy
y estamos esperando por las
postulaciones de las distintas fuerzas
políticas para determinar quiénes serán
los contendores en esta elección del 9
de enero